hello everyone and again welcome my name
is Bob Barker and I'm responsible for
the Google Apps products the journey I'm
going to take you on today goes back ten
years when we served up to the world
what we then called google apps for your
domain this is primarily centered on a
gmail offering a flagship email offering
that's used by over a billion users
today act abuses but in time we added
calendaring unique cloud-based real-time
collaborative editing video conferencing
and a host of other sweet services that
made that really rested in one
fundamental principle that people work
together they put work better together
in the cloud collaboratively and my word
what a journey it's been today we are
thrilled to have and honored perhaps
over two million customers who depend on
us every day to enable their employees
to be successful and as we work with
these customers we've learned we've
learned a tremendous amount of what it
takes make organization successful and
with that we have evolved and I couldn't
be more excited to announce today that
we have evolved into G suite g suite is
an integrated set of suite of
applications designed to enable workers
to collaborate better in the cloud with
the power of Google's machine
intelligence to enable them to work
smarter and my team by really expect
excited to invest in introducing G
sweetie you and you'll get a lot more
about this in the weeks and months to
come
alright but what does this really mean
for our customers and for our products
this industry has been fixated on
personal productivity for three decades
now and in the process a lot of good
things have happened we've all created
tools that we use every single day many
tools that we love to use some that we
love to hate but that's the current
claim at which we operate personal
productivity what G sweet aims to do is
to elevate that beyond to a couple of
levels first and I'll walk you through
this in the next few minutes we want to
think about teens as first class objects
what do teens do in organizations how do
they work together what journeys to the
embarked on their day-to-day lives then
from there we'll go on to what it takes
to make organizations successful great
so let's begin by thinking about people
the atomic units in an organization and
I'm going to dwell for the next few
minutes on a series of announcements
that I'm really excited about bringing
to you today on the power of machine
intelligence enabling people to be more
successful in your organization's it's
study by McKinsey estimates that the
average employee really gets about to
productive creative days in a week okay
so what you asked are they doing the
other three days well you're searching
for information is scheduling meetings
you're triaging email things that we
think of as mundane work that's where we
think that the power of artificial
intelligence we can make things
dramatically better the first example
i'm going to give you something we're
launching now comes from google drive
many of you are used to file systems to
file repositories and i'm sure you can
identify with this journey that people
go through over and over again you go
into your file repository you scratch
your head i know it's in there somewhere
do i search do eyebrows do i filter do a
try and guess who gave me that file and
on a good day a studies show that the
average employee spends 15 seconds each
time they come into a file repository
before they get to the file you're
looking for that's only on a good day
lots of people don't find what they're
looking for and then they go off and a
state colleagues and bug a whole bunch
of people across the organization so we
challenge our engineers and said we
googly we need to do better than this
this is what they came up with quick
access uses your activity patterns to
predictably serve up to you the file
that you are about to need just as you
arrive and drive okay now searching no
typing no clicking you come in there and
I've been using this feature for a few
weeks now and a lot of the time we get
it right and the best part of machine
intelligence and machine learning is as
the system learns it gets better and
better so that's the first to the unique
announcements I'm happy to make today in
Google Drive quick access we'll give you
your files even before you ask for them
all right so you've got the file you
wanted what do you want to do with it
I'm going to walk you through a series
of machine intelligence capabilities in
our document editors that we
collectively refer to as explorer
capabilities the first of these I'll do
as a demo and then after that I'll walk
you through the other capabilities and
I'm joined by my colleague Jeremiah
who's going to put up on the screen a
spreadsheet so this is exploring sheets
we have Jeremiah and the screen please
great so this is a spreadsheet of
somewhat fictitious sales data from the
last holiday season and what we can
bring here is the power of Google's
natural language processing the problem
we're trying to solve
is that a large fraction of people about
the third of people who use sheets have
no idea what formulas are they don't
want to know they want to do some
analysis they should be able to ask
questions and get the answers Jeremiah
is now going to ask a natural language
question just as an analyst might ask
okay so what's the average profit margin
sucks okay and if the demo gods are with
us out pops the answer point four five
okay and what it did underneath the
covers was to take that natural language
question and transcribe it in the
formula that jump just got executed
against the sheet let's try another
example Jeremiah it was the most popular
product I'm black friday okay fair
question you might ask and back comes
the answer butts right again this is
where we were able to take the power of
natural language processing and Jeremiah
do you mind showing that formula great
so right there he's shown you the fairly
complex formula that got drawn out of
that fairly not with natural language
quick right excellent thanks Jeremiah if
we could have the main slide back please
good well not quite can we switch back
please with excellent i'm going to now
briefly touch upon the explorer
functionality in a couple of other
settings in our document editors
exploring slides attacks the following
problem when you're creating a
presentation you want to get your
message across you want to get your
content in and deliver it you don't want
to lose more time formatting and
polishing and rounding the corners of
boxes that's not what you're here to do
what exploring slides thus is you drop
in your content and a couple of flakes
it automatically formats it into a
beautiful presentation that's going to
have your boss thinking that you stayed
up all night polishing the slides
great very quickly let me touch upon
exploring google docs for years ago in
2012 we launched a feature that we
called dots research where we coupled
the Google search engine into your darks
editor and it's somewhat gratifying to
see the world take notice and start to
do similar things right now but we
decided to go much further you want to
be able to compose a document about Neil
Armstrong and it starts to pull in
content about the Apollo 11 mission from
google Jesus genetic knowledge graph
that is the power of exploring dogs what
we can do is bring in related concepts
not live from the web but also documents
from your drive and shared content
across your company's repositories let
me turn to my next example calendars in
scheduling I've kind of been unchanged
for 200 years a calendar is a bunch of
boxes and a grid okay and in the system
is some poor soul who is hunched over at
terminal moving those boxes around all
day for a living this is the 21st
century folks that's not acceptable
right so we decided to change that
here's a fine time works launching today
in Android and iOS soon to come to the
web you know that a bunch of people have
to get together well we haven't yet
gotten to the point of guessing who
those people are but let's say you tell
us who this particular okay we then
figure out automatically looking at
everybody schedules understanding
people's meeting patterns and finally
the best time for them to meet to
maximize the probability the meeting
actually happens okay and in time as the
system learns we're going to get better
with things like finding the right room
for them to meet ya so the promised here
is scheduling should become more and
more automated and less and less reliant
and prone to human
error in trouble so as a result of this
you're going to start to see more
innovation in this space and in time you
shouldn't have those poor souls hunched
over terminals dealing with this stuff
alright went pause for a second and
reflect a little bit and all of this
machine intelligence capability I'm
going to begin with the confession i
worked in these technologies for two
decades and i will confess that i did
not foresee that a day would come in my
lifetime when computers would beat the
world go champion i did not foresee that
in a matter of months we could take the
same machine learning kernels and turn
it in an engine that answers ten percent
of emails automatically so smart reply
composes responses to emails and ten
percent of the time users are perfectly
happy using what the machine is composed
i did not foresee that in this
generation we'd have machines that could
take images or videos and annotate them
or real-time cloud-based translation
where you hold up a phone to a sign and
it gets translated into your language
and i attribute this to the maniacal
focus i found us Larry and Sergey put in
machine intelligence and forces all to
reexamine the assumptions on which we're
building these products now this second
point I want to make you there's a lot
of players out there talking about
artificial intelligence being the future
and that's great at Google artificial
intelligence is not the future its
current shipping reality and that's why
we're able to move from beating the
world go champion 40 years ahead of
schedule the products that use exactly
those same technologies in months this
is not a lab experiment what it takes is
a way of life a way of transcribing a
business problem into a metric
optimization that machine learning then
turns into beautiful experiences like
these all right
that's what I had to say about
individuals now let's uplift this to
develop of teen productivity because I
believe this is going to become
increasingly important in the years to
come so the point here is we need to
think of teams as first-class citizens
and how they go about doing their work
every single day okay and today and
pleased to make two announcements in the
shroud both going into early adopter
program today the first we call team
drives so what's teen bugs wow I didn't
realize that this be so popular so the
idea of team drives is to get away from
the notion that content is owned and
managed by individuals because at some
levels at some level people join a group
they leave and when the leave content
gets orphaned you don't want that right
so team drives is a setting where a team
is a first class object in terms of its
ownership of content themes manage
content assign content to other people
and all of this is fully dynamic as the
identity of a team keeps changing
because people can join a team people
can exit 18 and all of that lead stream
content unaffected all right the second
announcement I want to bring you is a
new hangouts experience for video when
you make a phone call you don't pick up
your phone and say it's that person on
verizon or water phone do they have an
iphone android you just dial the number
in ear off to the races it's the same
fluidity want to bring to video
conferences it should be just a seamless
to make a video content so the new
hangouts experience also entering early
adopter program today offers the
following features first as always with
Google no downloads no plugins
nothing extraneous simple link based
video conferencing no identity so you
can easily communicate with partners
with customers with anybody outside your
domain candidates things should be
looked every single day moreover every
meeting by default this has been one of
our biggest requests from customers by
default every meeting has a phone
numbers so if you just caught in the
airport security line at the time of the
video conference and experience i'm sure
everyone if we can relate to you don't
have to find a nice place where you're
visible just pick up the phone and join
it right as simple as making a phone
call expect to hear more from us in this
area but the new google hangouts video
experiences in early adopters also
starting today alright so i've talked
about people i've talked about the next
layer of teams as I said you should
expect to hear more announcements this
area from us with other products let's
now up level it to the success of the
organization ok and really the goal here
is to break down the information silos
in enterprise three months ago we
launched a unique cloud-based search and
assist capability that we call
springboard what this gives you is the
ability to harness all of the content in
your enterprise where the first part
your third party bring it into a single
index and first of all provide secure
search search that sensitive the
reorganizations so you have a reorg and
instantly content you're not privy to
it's hidden from you or if you become
privy to content conversely you can
access that content through the search
functionality ok this is technically
pretty challenging and I'm thrilled to
say my team's pull yourself but there's
more you're all familiar with Google now
in the consumer site in similar fashion
with enterprises this capability
proactively provides you assist
capability so when you're walking into a
meeting the assist capability surface as
a document says yes a document you're
going to need for that meeting okay and
if you look really carefully at the
screenshot the document being suggested
here comes not from google but from box
with whom we just signed a partnership
to be able to surface exactly this kind
of content okay so it doesn't have to be
just Google content it's whatever is
relevant to your business right so that
in summary is G sweet a suite of
applications designed to make your
business runs model